welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question quarantine Edition
through daily dose abstraction giving
you too much information about the one
dirty thing we're still allowed to do so
long as it's you know fictional
superheroes in our imaginations how you
doing over there Phillip I'm doing so
well and getting everything done I've
grown three inches since yesterday
everything is going so well how are you
I'm doing okay those of you at home know
that we did our best last week to
protect ourselves with you know gloves
plastic wrap lots lots of personal space
which I prefer any given day but we're
now no longer allowed to leave our homes
so we are we're doing our best here to
keep these episodes coming at you bear
with us
I know one thing by the way that has
been on my mind very much about just
being stuck at home and that's uh what
kind of action can we get what are we
talking about here
especially if you're alone all things
are available to you and no one can
judge right now you be you it doesn't
matter nothing matters anymore it's
nothing they also then got got to
thinking kind of how remember last week
you asked me about my nightmares so I
want to ask you about your nightmares
and that's sex stuff because I know that
your wet nightmares are something that's
played you for a long time I
specifically want to know okay so they
say if you have a partner who is being
safe right now
I in washing their whole body head to
toe in the sink constantly then you guys
can engage in relations that's what
they're saying the CDC said it not me
but I'm wondering what about our
favorite heroes cuz a lot of them I feel
like are just we're just rip people in
half if they shoot lasers out of their
eyes and what else do they shoot lasers
that up so I want to know Erik is it
possible and who exactly can I'm
specifically I'm very curious about my
man Holt because no one can withstand
that
well the question of superheroes in has
been really the most important debate
ever since our nerd father Kevin Smith
brought it up in Mallrats remember that
whole debate do you think your fallopian
tubes could handle this sperm I
guarantee blows a load like a shotgun
right there
back so you know here at new rock stars
whether it's Palpatine or whether it's
Hulk we are honored to do and our
parents are disappointed no matter what
we do
so just supported and disgusted well
Philip you know we've been rewatching
the Infinity Saga films lately and the
most recent breakdown we've released in
the channel is the Incredible Hulk he
had Norton 1 and there's a scene where
Bruce Banner and Betty Ross make out in
a motel room the Bruce gets a little too
turned on his heartrate monitor beeps
like crazy and then he asked to pull out
yeah alright yeah cuz well no he's not
in but he have to pull away from this
situation she's not like purple spandex
she doesn't expand to fit whatever size
he needs it Infinite's
the proportions well it's implied really
from there forward in the MCU that Bruce
cannot have any romantic interactions to
that extent like he's really the master
of isolation and social distancing and
Black Widow does develop that calm down
technique on you know the whole palm
stroke thing come up I wouldn't call
that sexual we you're doing it wrong
according to rule 34 there exists a
whole palm stroke fetish probably we
don't kink shame here I'm sure some
people find that sexist and a man that
hold beer box below your palm stroke
magma magma do not send us your magma
whatever you interpret that like I can
get into that like the the size
comparison stuff you know Beauty and the
Beast had that thing with Beast and her
tiny tiny little hand yeah does he have
that not that dogs get do you know what
I'm talking about
like the paw but it has little claws
that stick out of it no that's not what
I mean oh I think it's a thing I'm not
I'm not a veterinarian but I have form
surgery on cattle but I think dogs the
end of it expands so that it can't be
pulled out easily along the middle
and I'm just saying beast boats from
x-men and from beauty and probably had a
not dick
let's close to home Eric I'm just glad
we're not sharing a space right now
okay the longer I need subtext with
Bruce Banner in these movies is that
he's a Virg he's really the classic in
cell if you think about it he can never
have sex and he probably holds some
resentment towards the opposite sex for
about that class but here's the deal man
Hulk actually does he so much but that's
in the comics and possibly in the
embassy we'll get to that in a bit
I want to start with actually talking
about a few superheroes who are not so
lucky
oh okay poor Bucky no you know that guy
oh yeah Sebastian Stan i'ma stand yeah
that guy gets it yeah he gets it let's
start with rogue so by definition of her
superpowers rogue is a rogue she absorbs
the life force mutant abilities of
everyone she makes skin contact with she
can't have romantic relationships like
that but isn't it no glove no love maybe
so blood love you can have glove love
but even then that's just heavy petting
how do you do intercourse with gloves I
guess we should ask Morman wait hold on
Eric do you think no glove no loves me
you can't have sex if you're not wearing
gloves a glove is a condom what condom
you said glove in terms of rogue so I'm
picturing rogues famous gloves and she
also had gloves but she she can have
intercourse if someone is wearing a
condom and that's me a full body size
condom they just keep their pants on
they only unzip that's what the whole
store in the boxers and there's gonna be
skin I mean there's got a can't control
it I'm okay with losing a little bit of
my life force to get with rogue by the
way chisaem I'm sure a couple people are
I mean we saw in the x-men movies she
kisses that dude she nearly kills him
because it's a not gay Iceman and she
breathes out cold air to be fair we
don't know that he's not gay they're
still like high school-aged he's really
good at theater and singing that's truth
by the way but right he's also a great
Animorph damn it has this become an
Animorph step aside yes it has
well actually there is a comic excellent
three her sexual frustration so bad it
drives her to try to get rid of her
powers that's I've had it Wow
so really no glove no love now some
people have said there are mutants that
you could hook up with like there's a
mutant leech who's a Morlock lives New
York sewers he temporarily negates the
powers of other mutants but the problem
is he's like a developmentally
challenged kid so probably not okay just
has to be in the room it's a proximity
thing with them so yeah he's just
watching but being in the room is
probably enough for Chris Hansen sitting
down to eat again being in the wrong
place
glass of milk to go on with those
cookies oh you some of also said that
she could hook up with Colossus if he's
in his metal house wander into the room
but also like have you seen the way his
metal farm works it's like a suit of
armor and I bet right on those lines
there's a lot of pinch points there it's
it's rogue it's best to stay away
probably but also let's move on to the
thing Ben grandma Ben Grimm does not
have genitalia
it just rocks down we sure in fact wait
for sure rocks in a string of seven
minutes just like like Kendall rocks
Kendall rocks blame Kendall versions
girlfriend Alicia dumps him in dates
Johnny Storm and when she hooks up with
Johnny she says it's the first time in
ages that she got any action so the
plies yeah Ben Grimm doesn't have
anything down there so you don't just he
pee and poop that's a wonderful question
that should be do baby I mean he looks
like hood I've said it a million times
he looks so good
let's move on to some people who it's
been long debated whether or not so
they're like the maybe category Superman
okay so Superman is the big the big
question here even before Kevin Smith's
Mallrats debate there was a 1969 essay
by Larry Nye then called Man of Steel
woman of Kleenex
which I don't know if he made Kleenex in
that context then but really he's saying
because he's the Man of Steel any woman
that he sleeps with decided to tear
apart like oh my god like a cheap tissue
that you sneeze through yeah oh my gosh
what a terrible in its yes so the essay
is fascinated at a
sizes house Superman's Kryptonian sperm
would just be too powerful with damage
the woman's uterus it's kind of what
Kevin Smith was siding with them all
yeah I always thought like he bangs he
bangs like a bullet to the brain and
then at the top of the head back a
victim's head blown outwards consistent
with a firearm discharged in her mouth
an old lady across the hall says she
heard someone yell here comes a super
load yeah yeah there have been a number
of comics showing Lois Lane you know in
a sexual relationship with Superman they
have kids so it just depends on which
comic writer is taken over that
storyline it suggested that Superman has
the ability to limit his intensity so
that he doesn't kill the person he's
sleeping yeah that's true he supposedly
has precise control over every single
like cell of his body so for instance
you might remember that he can mimic
other people's voices because he can
control his vocal cords so precisely
yeah so I guess he can do these minut
little movements but I mean he's not
liking doing that he wishes he could
just watch I mean he's Superman so part
of what of his super abilities is like
that tenacious d song he can softly
that's why it makes so much more sense
in the new 52 when he gets with Wonder
Woman that's right and that's on to our
next subject Wonder Woman so Wonder
Woman has Superman sex all the time
she's a Greek goddess she has like
resistance and they're evenly matched
and I think that's the key so Diana can
have sex just like Superman she just has
to restrain herself if she's having sex
with someone who is not a god basically
she can't really go full well I mean
you've seen the boys oh I've seen the
boys they just have to be careful like
that's we're talking about a pop claw
there you know where she uses her legs
to crush her poor building managers head
yeah we have a footage of us recreating
this with a watermelon and people have
also talked about that in terms of
jessica jones like she's sexually
frustrated she can't have sex with
everybody but she does look up with Luke
Cage in that season and they destroy her
bed yeah well and one Buffy gets with
spoiler alert spike they tear down a
whole house when they do it or like
Bella and Edward in Breaking Dawn they
destroy that bed - just give me a second
you just destroy your bed it's been
obliterated down here okay but now we
got to talk about our boy Hulk so unlike
our boy Ben Grimm Hulk does have a dog
and what a dog he gets naked an
Incredible Hulk number 400 and his
nemesis of the leader comments on how
well-endowed E is weights do they show
it like with the cover
or it's like a folding page also in the
MCU thor ragnarok thor does see him
naked and i would say his reaction says
it all like that guy has he's packing
something to my brain now so here's the
deal though when banner slash Hulk
reaches the point of stasis in Hulk form
it's implied he's totally capable of
having sex in thor ragnarok he spends
two and a half years on Sekar solely in
hulk form he's a celebrity gladiator
right and then an endgame he reached the
balance is smart Hulk and he's been in
that state for about three and a half
years and once again is a celebrity and
if you think Hoke didn't either those
forms you're crazy but what woman on
earth could take that it would have to
be a woman not on earth right so Hulk
all the time in the comics so the
Ragnarok Sekar storyline was based on
the Planet Hulk storyline where Hulk as
a celebrity gladiator has sex with
caiera the old strong she's an alien
who's basically impervious to harm and
he takes it fine there's also some
comics where Bruce gets cured of his
whole problem and he's able to have sex
with Betty when they get married when
he's like in human form boring no thanks
there's another time it's mythology gets
reversed if we switches from peaceful
Hulk to savage puny human and what he's
able to have sex with savage Bruce to
calm him down into peaceful holes ha so
I love that yeah now there's some other
really weird stuff that goes on like
Hulk comes under a an erotic influence
like eros tries to do psychically seduce
him with waves of pleasure as Hulk is
rampaging through New York eros is super
gross and I hope we never
see Arison name see you there's gonna be
a lot of problems if that happens
there's also Hulk becomes grey Hulk and
he's the Las Vegas enforcer yeah I mean
it has sex with a human aerobics
instructor
her name's Marlo Chandler and in the
comics it's real weird she seems super
smitten afterwards like she hugs this
lamp Pole and she's got this big smile
and she goes I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
actually thought she was gonna die
flying or she's like I guess I'm okay
but my takeaway from that she's hugging
the lamp Pole I don't think there was
intercourse there I think she might have
done other she's an aerobics instructor
she's flexible you know like I mean yeah
I don't want to spell it out see I think
I wha you should because I'm completely
confused Li you mean I think you mean
that her hugging the lamppost is what
she did to his dog she she like she
fireman pulled her oh yeah she's like
you know there's also like an ultimate
Wolverine versus Hulk comic where Logan
tracks down banner to this mountain
palace and there's no women around but
then he swings open the doors and Hulk
is being lavished over by a harem I've
seen this for days three women in
bikinis I've seen this for a variety of
reasons when I was going on it's a crazy
image and what did they do how did they
do it I think they all it was a group
effort probably right oh that makes
sense actually okay does it make sense
well hold on I know I don't I'm not a
prude and I'm not going to get into
details because even though there should
be no children watching this I would
have been watching this video happily if
I if it were me and I was a kid uh
but I'm just gonna acknowledge because
there's people in the comments probably
acknowledging it there there are videos
that exist of very talented women who
could make anything happen happen so
thinking about you're referring to
live-action videos I was referring to a
multitude of animated film so you can
find it
where suddenly the physics of the human
body are contorted no I'm just saying
well yeah in animation sure it
everything it myself
yeah but I just mean like in real life
turns out you know the human pocket also
can do very insane thanks I'm not saying
from my own experience that's not my
kink but if it's nothing wrong with that
one so I'm sure there's nothing wrong
with any kink unless it's illegal which
this might be illegal breaking a person
murder murder is illegal okay well
really the most version of Hulk having
sex is in the old man Logan storyline
kind of the loose inspiration for the
Logan film Hulk is a slumlord in
Sacramento he has like this incestuous
family clan that helps dominate these
these tenants his wife or his lover is
his cousin she-hulk Oh God
they're related and they have kids and
they're all messed up it's disgusting
but that's kind of the whole point of it
it's real great because they're all
freaks yeah hope including family so you
folks family like I don't want to call
comic book writers pervy but obviously
the craziest hero to imagine having sex
is Hulk and apparently he's the one that
they've been like let's go to that well
again and again I think we will make it
work like like it's like we've covered
this before not enough we haven't
thought it with what about 42 women what
about an acrobat good what about his
country
shut up Merle okay so in summary to
answer your question some superheroes it
cannot some can but under the condition
that they limit themselves by their
intensity or they explore alternatives
to straight-up intercourse but Hulk
Courtney definitely do [ __ ] him I'm an
Palpatine though I know about the book
that says he doesn't but he still does
all right I am as
despite as they are not literally I mean
you can't see satisfied metaphorically
satisfied
okay well shifting gears for a second
here Philip I don't know about you my
entire life including this conversation
has shifted completely online it went
from like being 75% online to a hundred
percent online and these past days I've
been very aware of online security and I
want to make sure I can access all the
streaming content that I want to get and
really everyone no matter where they
live should have access to shouldn't
have to worry about it well thank you to
our brains and expressvpn for sponsoring
this episode
oh yes I've been using this post bpn
because we always talk about how it
protects your privacy and your security
or whatever but specifically a lot of
people will forget it's a VPN that means
you can watch shows and movies that
you're not allowed to watch in your like
region and that specifically came up the
other day I pulled up a thing I was
trying to watch a very old episode of a
TV show they could not find anywhere and
I went to go play it couldn't be played
in my region logged in through
expressvpn and I could yeah their shows
like Doctor Who Rick and Morty they're
not available on the US Netflix but are
available in the UK Netflix all these
rules are crazy and it's tied up with
stupid like media company laws and what
they have their restrictions and the
access and the licence to but like that
shouldn't limit you just because you
want to watch it you just happen to be
living somewhere else
so really it's simple with expressvpn
you just fire up the expressvpn app you
change your location you refresh Netflix
Hulu whatever you're using and that's it
yeah it does it on the IP level so you
can actually just pick like what of a
hundred different countries or something
what country you just want to seem like
you're streaming from there are hundreds
of VPNs out there but expressvpn is
ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering or lag and you can stream an
HD without problems expertise VPN is
also compatible with your devices your
phone's Media Console Smart TVs and more
and you can watch what you want on a
personal device or on the big screen
wherever you are so guys please check it
out via our special link it's expressvpn
dot-com slash big Q and there you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free yes support the show watch what
you want
protect yourself with expressvpn at
expressvpn comm slash big q alright
we're now gonna move on to some
bite-sized questions builds gonna answer
these really we just have one bite sized
but it's gonna be a big bite Philip what
are the differences between Marvel's
Thor and the Norse God a Thor I've been
wanting to get into this for quite a
while because there's a bunch so what
here's what's really fun about it
there's actually though not as many
differences as there should be like if
you think about it it's like Oh Iron Man
was written at a certain time and Batman
or Superman would get my Batman figurine
Superman whatever these characters are
all kind of relatively of the last
hundred years or so and then weirdly
they through in this Norse God from like
millennia ago and like yeah let's keep
most of it's like if Jesus was also a
character and Marvel and they were like
yeah you still like the Son of God kind
of like they kept a lot of Thor's and
Norse origins they just treat a couple
of things I love that Jesus's Power Move
is changing water in the wine of the
post-credits scene we're keeping all of
his mythology points yeah in Canon it's
that a age of Ultron scene where they're
all live via headset like what they're
doing
Hawkeye it's like I'm taking care of
this Jesus what are you doing I'm
walking over the lake then raised thanks
so much the rest of us can fly why is it
that every week we get sacrilegious and
specifically psych Christian religious
anyway back to the whole point of this
Norse Thor versus MCU Thor first up
appearance they don't look the same it's
not like hugely different but
specifically Eric I'm so sorry he's not
a blond beard he's not even blond-haired
it's all red he's a ginger ginger hair
ginger beer yeah yeah okay they
apparently when they were designing the
character for the MCU they considered
using red hair and they're like now too
creepy you know that sounds like some
bigotry toward gingers I'm a natural
redhead I can prove it but I won't I'm
good with that
up next one of the biggest changes
between the MCU and Norse mythology
which I can't believe I'm saying that
sentence uh is just the character of
Loki like everything about Loki Loki in
mythology
a much bigger deal and he's a much
better deal is a pretty big bag deal in
them see you well let me go through it
first of all just talking about
relations there he is not Thor's brother
he's actually okay Jordan's stepbrother
so he's at a whole like level higher
like the Odin level of gods yeah I mean
you can understand why they changed that
because being a antagonists or Thor and
their brothers it's kind of interesting
and more challenging than like oh no my
step uncle I mean but my step uncle is
kind of an [ __ ] so I I would relate
but most people can brother it's more
intimates rivalry yeah or if you're in
that Holt family on that farm it's a
very intimate come back to Loki
differences and just sticking with this
different relationships thing and family
relations Loki has a lot of baby mamas
out there he has a lot of kids and
they're all bad but they're all like
also like weirder than just kids like
first of all he has it's like trio of
kids that he has with this a giant s
lovely large lady I in her on nice yes
every day and anger boda
which is I mean a name that implies
giant s I would think and they're
terrible but then he also has a kid that
is a serpent named German GERD or yeah I
believe that's correct pronunciation
rookie uh and that's not that weird
right because he also has a wolf child
named Fenrir that's right which Fenrir
so in Ragnarok yeah yeah which is also
you know that's his child but also
inspired the character in Harry Potter
Oh
Hagrid but there's one very interesting
kid too that he has a daughter named
hella hella hella is now that one Loki's
daughter not interesting right and on
top of that if you're looking into the
real hella versus the well the real
hello that exists in our real world each
not insult she is kind of beautiful like
Cate Blanchet a half her side half her
face have her body and then the other
half is
literally dead like to face yeah kind of
as hot as two faces mmm
it also makes me think that's what I was
talking about with the Thanos half dead
and then also Loki never gets Redemption
that's so saying where he just is like
batter he just stays bad in fact in
Norse mythology in Ragnarok he turns on
all the other gods including Thor and he
fights against them in Ragnarok he's the
one that actually leads the army of the
Dead against Asgard not hella in the
actual regner yeah that sounds more
Norse like people don't have like
Redemption stories it's mythology you
know like people are bad they're heroic
yeah yeah they actually also Thor and
Loki both died in Ragnarok everyone dies
right so that's like a much more badass
horse version of it and then speaking
the floor really quick to some quick
changes to him he can't fly the way he
kind of like throws me on the air with
some momentum and then like that you
know makes Thor fly he has a chariot
pulled by two just majestic goats
they're named tooth Nasher and tooth
grinder those are greatness yeah I mean
my firstborn is gonna be named both
sexes at the left half will be one of
the Dead half will be named grinder and
then the really sad part about that is
that he eats them when he gets hungry
and then the next day he resurrects them
but I think their memories are probably
intact like no hey remember everything
and then we also know that he has a
magic belt they actually have
representing them see you happy finds it
and he tries to pronounce it and you
can't but just Thor's magic belt but he
also has magic gloves and that's
actually necessary for him to wield
Mjolnir they're very special and they're
called jargon beer to her could they fit
that on the glove logo and then finally
probably maybe the thing you'd probably
guess the most easily there's no Jane
Foster in Norse mythology there is a
Natalie Portman though weirdly no I you
know who he gets with and is actually
kind of like a hot awesome pairing and
it's kind of like the Superman to Wonder
Woman he gets with Lady SIF yeah yeah
that makes sense
that's pretty hot he just kind of like
he's sort of into her in the in the
Marvel world too you know she's just
like his old fling it's kind of
long-term buddy so Thor Fox but we knew
that Thor I mean constantly even fad
Thor well you know this I feel like
Taika Waititi got to make some of these
changes for Thor love and thunder this
is a version of Thor in the north's
characters that I want to see in the MCU
which version the one with gloves
oh yeah nobody knows I with the goats
I wanted to face I want I want Fenrir to
come back and I want him to have a
bigger role yay
you know it's time for the mailbox
question box fan box fan mail thing
segment we haven't named it
appropriately and I brought it with me
you took it good for you we still have
some in here luckily from before the
apocalypse and so this one I'm pulling
is from oh this is a very famous person
Wow
can't believe they're a fan okay crazy
alright what is the furthest you've
gotten by faking it til you make it
oh well that that questioner is
definitely faked it till they make tit
yeah definitely I'd really made it too
crazy ooh
Phillip Phillip and I have an
interesting story I don't know if you
have another story I have one that
involves both of us when we faked it so
we made it
am I gonna be comfortable with this yeah
it's the
we'll do a guy story so in college
Philip made this it was actually a
pretty good web series that our whole
improv group all kind of helped make and
we were casting for a grouchy college
professor character so Philip put an ad
on Craigslist and we got a response from
this guy who was like 65 former cop with
the Boston Police Department and he now
goes the auditions for these things to
play like a cop in these movies this guy
was terrifying and Philips like all
right what we need to like make it as
legit as we can because this is just
like a no budget college web series that
we're doing but Eric you have to like
you have to trick them into thinking
that it's like a bigger deal production
than it is so don't want him to know
we're in college students right so we
were trying to like look older than we
were look more professional than we were
and I had to keep this guy busy do I
know this story
yeah what did you do you said fake it
till you make it to anything gonna print
out some sides for them and you have to
make them loopy asks any questions just
getting kind of a run around don't tell
them what it is make it sound like this
is like a real TV show that we're
producing in Gainesville Florida on this
college campus so I had to talk to this
guy he kept asking what it was and I
said well it's it's a very big deal we
were in partnership with the with the
campus Residence Hall Association it's
going to have a market of the entire
Gainesville area and we just got our
budget approved and kept trying to like
sat and he was looking right through me
this guy's a former detective
so he's like he's looking right through
me he could tell that he's just like
ready to snap my neck with it you
brought me here to this this classroom
this isn't even a real student union
room that you said it was it's just a
classroom in this we have a professor
coming in he is telling us see we aren't
allowed to pee in here what are you
really up to kid and when Philip shows
up like 40 minutes later from the
computer lab with some printed outsides
because we didn't have a script
and it was just like he went to IMDB
quotes and printed out lines from Harry
Potter and these well it was
specifically the world the Goblet of
Fire her role was for a professor type
and I just I had not seen or read any
Harry Potter and so I was like isn't
there a famous professor in there I bet
there's a lot of professor he lines so I
was like Harry Potter professor quotes
and he printed out the lines for mad-eye
moody talking about the unforgivable
curses but you didn't want this guy to
think that it was from Harry Potter
because he wanted you wanted them to
think it was like sides for our thing
I'm like a serious thing a serious like
dramatic piece so Philip went through
all the character names in this I'm to
be quotes and change them to just random
names but forgot to go in the line
itself and change the line so it's like
Professor Stevens says and he's read the
line this guy goes so I'm supposed to
teach you the unforgivable curses
talking about curses and he goes
Dumbledore wanted me to tell you what
these cuts is all about so you're better
prepared hey Miss Granger
you know what the cases are and then he
lowers the scripting looks at me and he
goes is this from Harry Potter he shot
you can he kill me and I met goes if you
ever hear Eric and I say Dumbo yeah like
damn belljo it's just an apple damn yeah
like just the weirdest Dumbledore wanted
me to say these cases this is Boston cup
accent or whatever was just saying dude
one of these days I want to walk up to
your door
you're Dumbledore and see you're not
there so you know that you went on the
move on to a better life he did not get
the part we have we did Gaza because we
were scared of him
I know not interest real quick I'll say
I'll say that you I couldn't think of
one until you reminded me that we did a
lot of posting on Craigslist at that
time because I just remembered that we
all lived in a house you lived there for
a stretch too but yeah but I think he
didn't live there yet you were just like
one of the frequent visitors but it was
like 10 people living in the same house
all from our comedy group and we were
ending college and talking about all the
crazy stuff that we wanted to do
now we still like wanted to be crazy and
then somebody I don't think it was me
I don't think it was you but if somebody
in our group was like yeah like you know
we should have had an orgy by now which
by the way only happens in porn that's
not like a college trope like and then
you have your college or Jean like the
part of your your conversation with your
parents or anything up to Gainesville
but it was set as if like yeah yeah we
should have had heard you by now and so
this part was me because I am very much
an instigator I was like well what let's
have one we'll have one I said when is
Tuesday crew uhh
and so everyone was like yeah let's do
it and we were all like hyping each
other up and I'm sure we were drunkest
I'll uh and I was not in the room for
this conversation I heard about it later
but I was not there for this you
attended the eventual event I'm pretty
sure actually that did oh yes I
participated in that party so I I just
decided to like the only thing we knew
at the time that of like how to like get
to sex was the they used to had the
casual encounters section on Craigslist
which was just like you just want to
hook up and so we all sat there around
the computer and and wrote up this ad of
like hey we're a bunch of young college
comedians and we're looking to have an
orgy are you interested we have a house
we thought that was cool and then and
then like what we were looking for in
the women which are like is super not
who's on on that licking but anyway and
then at the end we're like oh we got
included a picture so we were like well
we need a picture of like with all ten
of us so literally posted a picture of
us like performing on stage like just
from one of our stupid cheesy college
comedy shows I and that's it wasn't it
web picture of a ride on at Disney World
and maybe also oh we definitely put some
more than one picture you did just
remind me because we wanted to show like
do you know would perform on stage we're
cool even though it's like so nerdy and
we were your matching shirts but then
and I'll have like little bird bodies
but then yeah and then maybe that's
going to Disney World I think was in
there um which you're definitely in both
those pictures and then we posted it and
then we're like kind of yeah cool and
then we said oh we're throwing a party
this Friday and that's where we want the
orgy to happen and then everyone
kind of like forgot about it but I had
it set up to like send to an email so I
start getting all of these requests and
I get them like almost immediately of
people and like women and they're
sending their pictures of just that want
to do this orgy they love this idea of
10 college guys or they're so looks
crazy and then so we're still in the
heat of it or still like like not so far
later that I do respond with like okay
the party's this night and and here's
our address and then like but like a
full day passes and I even start to kind
of forget about it but then eventually I
kind of open this email and I see a lot
of replies start coming in and are like
confirming that they're attending and I
Sai stop responding to any of this and
but but it doesn't stop rolling in and
then that party happens no one remembers
this order at this point I don't bring
it up to anyone because I don't want
everyone to know that like guys these
people are coming here to our party so I
just stay quiet about it and those party
we had that big house leave this party
was huge there were a ton of strangers
at this party
and there were a lot of closed doors of
different rooms I have no idea what
ended up happening but I a hundred
percent I think I spent like the night
talking to you about like some stupid
sketch show we want to do or something
I very much just like that like picked a
certain moment to be like and no longer
gonna fake the ability to like have been
nerve to go through with this what a
[ __ ]
yes I don't know everyone who is at that
party which was rare because most of our
friends just the same 30 or 40 people
who we knew and didn't know anyone
outside of that friend group so it was
weird to see strange faces and strange
everything changed holes but you know
what's terrifying is like most of the
people who responded to that were
probably dudes they're probably dudes in
their 40s and 50s who were catfishing us
and just gonna show up to this party and
see what happened
me yeah actually right they're probably
like oh there's gonna be girls there
probably I can just sneak into the
gangbang no one no one's taken role in a
file would you say can you just say I
get every name when I have an orgy
people wear name tags that's it just
named damn Bulldog Dumbledore
he was there I'm behind you per se he
said all is forgiven walk guys we could
have never seen each other again thanks
so much for watching this last episode
of big question every episode is the
like every episode is her last a
reminder that you can join us on discord
and ask us questions there a lot of the
discord questions end up inspiring
episodes of the show and you can join
discord might be kind of a patron of new
rock stars at patreon.com slash new rock
stars and a reminder that you can get
audio versions of the show by
subscribing to new rock stars a big
question wherever you get your podcasts
you can follow me at EA vas everywhere
you can follow a fill up at Phillip
Malina and reminder to send us your
questions everywhere that you can reach
out to us in the comments of this video
using the hashtag big question on social
media you can also mail us a torpedo box
which you don't know you don't have
memorized no guys thank you so much
remember to share the show with a friend
if you liked it and if you don't like it
shut your damn mouth hey we're still
figuring out let us know if you have any
other ideas of ways that we can talk to
each other keep these shows coming out
because we aren't slowing down
no pandemic and slow us down alright and
then feel free to spawn to our email if
you're interested in our orgy the new
rock stars orgy hashtag a big take down
that post oh no it's still rolling in
millions of responses over time it's how
the virus spreads yeah soon it is
alright guys have a good one